peter j lightheart is president of the
theopolis institute in birmingham
alabama
where he also serves as teacher at
trinity presbyterian church
he received a ba in english and history
from hillsdale college
a master of arts in religion and a
master of theology
from westminster theological seminary
and a phd from the university of
cambridge
he has served as pastor of reformed
heritage presbyterian church
now trinity presbyterian church and as
pastor of trinity reformed church in
moscow idaho
a former professor of theology and
literature at new saint andrews college
and a bi-weekly columnist for first
things dr lightheart
is the author of numerous books
including a two-volume commentary
on revelation and most recently baptism
a guide to life from death
please join me in welcoming dr
lightheart
thank you gretchen thanks to matt bell
and thanks to everyone associated with
cca
for inviting me as gretchen mentioned i
am a graduate of hillsdale
college i realized to my shock
earlier this weekend or this week that
it's been 40 years since i graduated
that's a shocking number
it's very good to be back here it's a
very different school than i attended as
you can imagine
this none of this existed many of the
buildings didn't exist
and it's always a delight to be back
here and to
get reacquainted with some old friends
and to be able to speak to you
students and other visitors to the cca
i want to do a couple of preliminaries
before i begin the first is my usual
disclaimer whenever i talk about jane
austen
and the disclaimer is that i know there
are dozens
in this room who know jane austen's
novels better than i do
so i beg your indulgence
the second preliminary i'm going to try
to get you to do something for me
i wrote a book called miniatures and
morals some years ago
which is a study of jane austen's six
published novels and uh
i titled my introduction real men
read austin
because of course men especially young
men think that they're girly books
but they're not and so i've tried this
before with not much success
i've tried to get a crowd to chant with
me real men read austin
so i'm going to say it once and then i
want to join you to join in
and three times i want you to say real
men read austin i'll
i'll set the rhythm by saying it myself
first
real men read austin real
men read austin real men
read austin real men read
austin thank you that was
far more successful than the last
attempt
and i hope you young men and older men
out there who have not read austin are
now ashamed
of your lack of reading my topic tonight
is morality and jane austen
and i am going to read my paper i'll try
to make some eye contact occasionally
but
just to make sure i stay within my time
limit and say everything that i had
planned to say
i'll be reading let me outline what i
have to say about jane austen and
morality
uh first i want to examine the
miniaturism of austin's
style and storytelling second i'll
explain how her miniaturism determines
the scope
of her moral concerns by that i mean the
zone within which the moral life is
lived out
third i want to show that austin's
literary style
expresses the substance of her moral
outlook
style isn't merely a surface phenomenon
for austin
rather austin's style exemplifies a view
of the world in a moral
perspective and models the comic
discernment
and truth-telling that she wishes to
instill in her readers
a well-known quotation from another
woman writer will orient us
at the outset in an 1850 letter to the
editor w
s williams charlotte bronte complains
that austin's novels are ought to get
altogether too tranquil
austin ruffles her readers by nothing
vehement
disturbs him with nothing profound the
passions are perfectly
unknown to her she rejects even a
speaking acquaintance
with that stormy sisterhood
austin's problem in bronte's view is
that she keeps to surfaces
and never penetrates emotional depths
this is bronte again
her business is not half so much with
the human heart as with human eyes mouth
hands and feet what sees keenly
speaks aptly moves flexibly it suits her
to study
but what throbs fast and full though
hidden
what the blood rushes through what is
uns the unseen seat of life and the
sentient target of death
that miss austin ignores
bronte muster is only this backhanded
compliment
she does her business of delineating the
surface
of the lives of genteel english people
curiously well
there is a chinese fidelity a miniature
delicacy
in the painting i think there's much
wrong with bronte's assessment of
austin but she also gets something right
and though bronte would not have known
it
austin describes her own work in
remarkably similar terms in a letter
that she wrote to her nephew james
edward austin lee
her nephew had misplaced two and a half
chapters of a manuscript he had been
working on
and he'd mentioned that in a letter to
aunt jane and aunt jane sent this
teasing letter back
it is well that i have not been at
steventon lately she writes
and therefore cannot be suspected of
purloining them
two strong twigs and a half towards a
nest of my own would have been something
i do not think however that any theft of
that sort would have really been very
useful to me
what should i do with your strong manly
vigorous sketches full of variety and
glow
how could i possibly join them on to the
little bit of ivory
on which i work with sofina brush
as produces little effect after much
labor
we know from other letters that austin
made a deliberate decision
to devote her life to brush work on two
inch
bin two-inch bits of ivory in a letter
to her niece anna another writer
austin says you are now collecting your
people delightfully
getting them exactly into such a spot as
is the delight of my life
three or four families in a country
village is the very thing to work on
in another letter she advises anna to
write about what she knows
she advises her not to take her
characters that she's writing about
to ireland let the portmans go to
ireland
but as you know nothing of manners there
you had better not go with them
you will be in danger of giving false
representations
in reply to reverend james stanier
clarke's suggestion
that she write a romance austin bluntly
insists that she'll continue to paint
such pictures of domestic life in
country villages
as i deal in and she continues
i could no more write a romance than an
epic poem i could not sit down seriously
to write a serious romance under any
other motive than to save my life
and if it were indispensable for me to
keep it up and never relax into laughing
at myself or other people i am sure i
should be hung before i had finished the
first chapter
no i must keep to my own style and my
own way
and though may i may never succeed again
in that i am convinced that i should
totally fail
in any other austin's deliberate
miniaturism her focus on three or four
families
in a country village is evident in
virtually every facet
of her literary art she limits her
novels with respect to action so much so
that it's often said especially by male
readers i suppose
that nothing happens in austin's stories
that's true if you're expecting
overturned carriages car chases
or perhaps zombies
there's remarkably little violence or
even vigorous action
at worst marianne dashwood falls and
sprains her ankle on a hill
and later catches a bad cold or luisa
musgrove falls off a wall and gets a
nasty bump on her head
one critic has said that there was a
violent thing that happens in pride and
prejudice
occurs when elizabeth jumps over a style
on the way to visit her sister jane
at netherfield park in sense and
sensibility colonel brandon duels with
willoughby
no neither one is injured but that is
that scene is not shown
and it's spoken of so cryptically and
briefly that readers easily miss it
no one as far as i recall have been able
to find ever bleeds
in an austin novel but most importantly
austin is a miniaturist of style
she does more with less than any other
english writer
there's a precision and lack of
ornamentation in her prose
that i suspect owes much to the bible
and the book of common prayer
this makes her simply the most elegant
prose stylist and one of the most
innovative
in english literature after reading
austin every other writer
seems bloated even if i dare to
blaspheme
as stylish a writer is c.s lewis
let me give a guess oh i heard that i
heard the rejoinders
forming uh let me
give several examples to make my point
first austin pays her readers the
compliment of not spelling out every
detail of plots
she would have made a great mystery
novelist i think because she expects her
readers to draw conclusions from the
limited information that she provides
toward the end of pride and prejudice
for example lady catherine de berg shows
up at longborne as we saw in the movie
yesterday to pressure elizabeth darcy to
give up all hope of marrying mr darcy
during this spirited exchange which does
not in the original
become a ninja battle during the
spirited exchange lady catherine reveals
that she had received a report about the
engagement
two days ago earlier she had told mrs
bennett that she left the collins's
the night before last elizabeth later
puts the pieces together and realizes
that lady catherine
learn heard of the heard the rumor of
darcy's impending proposal
from mr and mrs collins but lady
catherine gives us all the facts we need
to put two and two together
ourselves similarly at several points in
emma
miss bates provides crucial information
about the puzzling relationship between
frank churchill and jane fairfax
but we need to pay careful attention to
her rambling gossip
to get the points few readers do
we as readers are as impatient with miss
bates
as emma is also at the end of emma
unlike the movie we saw this afternoon
mrs elton does complain about the lack
of elegance at emma's wedding
but the narrator tells us that she was
not even at the wedding
it says that she drew her conclusions
quote from the particulars
detailed by her husband
austin frequently leaves settings to the
reader's imagination as well
writing to her niece anna she offers
this advice you describe a sweet place
but your descriptions are often more
minute than will be liked
you give too many particulars of right
hand and left
austin often creates the illusion of a
scene with a few strokes and props
like a caricaturist who captures a face
with a line or two
on nightly's first visit to hartfield at
the beginning of emma
nothing in the room is mentioned besides
a backgammon table a fire
and the visitor there's no description
of knightley's physical appearance or of
the room
and even some of the props in the room
some of the objects in the room
are mentioned by the characters rather
than by the narrator
austin rounds off characters with an
economy that borders on the miraculous
after a little more than two pages of
dialogue at the beginning of pride and
prejudice
we know mr and mrs bennett their
relationship with each other their
relationships with their daughters
their hopes especially mrs bennett's
hopes their faults and follies mrs
bennett's nerves
and mr bennett's sardonic distance
this compressed characterization
frequently expresses austin's conviction
that syntax
is character how someone speaks
manifests his moral quality as much as
or even more
than what he says mr collins appears in
pride
before mr collins appears in pride of
prejudice he's been introduced by a
letter that he wrote
in which he discusses his breach with
the bennett family and his eventual
inheritance
of the ben at home at longborn this is
from his letter
the disagreement subsisting between my
between yourself and my later late
honored father
always gave me much uneasiness and since
i've had the misfortune to lose him
i frequently wish to heal the breach but
for some time i was kept back by my own
doubts
fearing lest it might seem disrespectful
to his memory
for me to be on good terms with anyone
with whom it always pleased him to be at
variance
as a clergyman moreover i feel it my
duty to promote and establish
the blessing of peace in all families
within the reach of my influence
and on these grounds i flatter myself
that my present overtures of goodwill
are highly commendable that the
circumstance of my being next in the
intel at longborne
will be kindly overlooked on your side
and not lead you to reject the olive
branch
anyone's whose speech or writing is as
convoluted
and oritanned as collins's cannot be
sensible
elizabeth gets him exactly right just by
hearing the letter she knows
there's something pompous in his style
and if the style
is pompous so is the man for austin's
characters just as for austin herself
style is substantive
one of my favorite examples of this
principle of syntax and character the
connection between syntax and character
comes from emma where austin relates mrs
elton's stream of consciousness during
the strawberry picking outing
at nightly's dunnell hall this is mrs
elton
the best fruit in england everybody's
favorite
always wholesome these the finest beds
and the finest sorts
delightful to gather for oneself the
only way of really enjoying them
morning decidedly the best time never
tired
every sort good oh boy infinitely
superior
no comparison the others hardly eatable
oh boy very scarce chili preferred
white wood finest flavor of all price of
strawberries in london
abundance about bristol maple grove
cultivations
beds when to be renewed gardeners
thinking exactly different
no general rule gardeners never been put
out of their way
delicious fruits only too rich to be
eaten much of
inferior to cherries currants more
refreshing
only objection to gathering strawberries
the stooping
glaring sun tired to death
could bear it no longer must go and sit
in the shade
mrs elton is all there the contradictory
opinions
each expressed with utter confidence
the randomness the reversion to her
obsessive themes like her home of maple
grove
the domineering know-it-allness
one fragmented paragraph captures a
whole person
and again it's not what she's saying
but how her mind moves that reveals her
character
one indication of collins poverty of
style and hence of his mind
is poverty of metaphor austin has been
characterized as a relentlessly
non-metaphorical writer but i think
that's
misleading though she rarely uses
explicit similes or metaphors are
languages
metaphorical in a more more profound
sense
she has an intuitive grasp of the
inheritance relatedness of things
and she often adapts language from one
realm of life
to describe another which is the essence
of metaphor
when she wishes she's capable of
producing striking metaphorical formulas
in emma during the strawberry picking
scene she writes of mrs
mrs elton's bonnet and basket as her
apparatus
of happiness she describes the aftermath
of elton's proposal to emma by saying
that their straightforward emotions left
no room for the little zigzags
of embarrassment and in sense
sensibility she refers to the puppyism
of robert fair's manners none of these
is
formally a metaphor but they all
manifest austin's profound metaphorical
imagination what austin despises is not
metaphor
but metaphors that are so overworked
that they ought to have been retired
in a letter to her niece anna she warns
against using the phrase vortex
of dissipation and she explains i do not
object to the thing
but i cannot bear the expression it is
such
thorough novel slang and so old
that i dare say adam met with it in the
first novel he opened
colin's use of olive branch is a sign of
his folly
for that metaphor is as old as noah if
not adam
metaphors tend to die and fossilize and
once that happens
they can be used without thought dead
metaphors shift the mind into autopilot
and thus hinder the arduous labor of
discernment
in a sense bronte was right austin
delineates the surfaces
of english life and she does it without
embellishment
in restrained crystalline prose
but this doesn't make her a superficial
writer
because her attention to surfaces opens
up an attention to substantive truth
and moral insight behind austin's
aesthetic decision to limit herself to
what she knows
is what could be called a philosophical
stance
that's vaguely nominalist particulars
often sensed are all we can talk about
with any degree of accuracy or detail
about universals we can say very little
since universals
by definition lack particular qualities
in northanger abbey henry tilney's
discourse on the theory of the
picturesque
ends ultimately in silence
delighted with catherine borland's
progress austin writes
and fearful of wearing her with too much
wisdom at once
henry suffered the subject to decline
and by an easy transition from a piece
of rocky fragment
and the withered oak which he had placed
near its summit to oaks in general to
forests
the enclosure of them wastelands crown
lands and government
he shortly found himself arrived at
politics and from politics
it was an easy step to silence
the broader the scope of discourse for
austin the less opportunity there is for
this fine discrimination
for the nuances and shades of difference
that are necessary
for true knowledge and sound judgment
the larger the scope of discourse the
more everything blurs into
undifferentiated
undifferentiated smoothness that austin
and many of her characters abhor but
it's precisely this
nominalism this my new testament
attention to the surfaces of character
and relation
that makes austin's work a continuing
source of moral instruction
because of her limitations she
emphasizes the domestic and local
contexts
for moral decisions and action the very
contexts in which most of our moral
decisions and actions
occur for austin the sensational doesn't
provide a sound basis for moral
reasoning
hers isn't a lifeboat ethics focusing on
marginal extremes of decision-making
on the contrary she recognizes that the
greatest moral challenges
come in the midst of daily life
precisely when
nothing is happening austin's
concentration on the kutidian
is related to what c.s lewis described
as austin's untragic
moral outlook her core convictions are
exacting
insofar as obedience is rigidly demanded
neither excuses nor experiments are
allowed
austin's principles provide the grammar
of con conduct
being something that anyone can learn
and something that everyone must
learn on the other hand our moral vision
is
lewis says unexacting insofar as the
duties commanded are not quixotic or
heroic
and obedience to them will not be very
difficult to properly brought up people
in ordinary circumstances austin is
untragic also in her
in the cheerful moderation of her joys
again this is lewis if she envisaged a
few great sacrifices
she also envisages no grandiose schemes
of joy
she has or at least all her favorite
characters have a hearty relish
for what would now be regarded as very
modest pleasures
a ball a dinner party books conversation
a drive to see a great house 10 miles
away a holiday as far away as derbyshire
these with affection and good manners
are happiness
unlike post-romantic novelists and
philosophers
austin doesn't pose ultimate questions
she doesn't struggle against devoid or
probe the mysteries of the universe
she doesn't doesn't pose these questions
because i think for her they were not
questions
they're settled a lifelong member of the
church of england a
preacher's kid a priest kid she believed
that the grand questions could be
answered by consulting
the 39 articles for austin the moral
challenge of life is not to puzzle out
the meaning of the universe but to live
well
in particular and given social and
domestic settings
the moral philosopher aleister mcintyre
discerns
an aristotelian strain in austin's
recognition that virtues are formed
tested and manifested within communities
as aristotle recognizes this makes
ethics a subdivision of politics the
question what should i do
is a sub question under what kind of
community do i live in
and what is my place in it for both
austin and aristotle the moral life is
status
specific to answer the question what
should i do in this case
we have to ask who am i and the latter
question is not about some ghostly inner
eye but out there about the role and
status that i have in a particular
social setting
darcy must not only ask as a bronte
character might
shall i who passionately love elizabeth
bennett's fine eyes
pursue elizabeth bennett he must also
consider the exterior of the situation
shall i with my name and status as an
english nobleman
pursue elizabeth bennett with her status
her name
and her family when knightley castigates
emma for her treatment of miss bates as
we saw in the movie this afternoon
he challenges her on precisely this
point consider your position in the
society of the town
he chides and the obligation your
position places on you
to show kindness to an unfortunate if
silly spinster like miss bates morality
is not about individuals
seeking to live a good life about
solitary decision makers striving for
ethical perfection
a moral person must learn to navigate
well among the surfaces of social life
given the well-defined strata of the
communities that austin deals in
this was a more obvious question for her
and for her characters than it might be
for us
but it's still a moral and a central and
perennial moral question
deciding what is right is never a simply
a matter of what should i
as a human being do it's always what
should i as a college student or as a
husband or wife or
as a car mechanic do in this or that
specific situation this is not
relativism it doesn't mean there are no
absolutes of right and wrong
but it does mean that the absolutes have
particular application to particular
people
in particular circumstances only a
sophomoric morality will ignore the
specificity
of our moral decisions and actions and
austin was no sophomore
in one important respect i think
austin's moral vision surpasses
aristotle's in the nicomachean ethics
aristotle distinguishes between
different sorts of action which he
describes as
poison and praxis production or poison
is different from praxis action and
aristotle says the reasoned
state that is capable of action is also
different from that which is capable of
production
hence neither is included in the other
because action praxis is not
police's production nor production
action
for aristotle ethics deals with practice
with intransitive action actions that
don't produce anything
outside of the actor but bear fruits
only in the character and virtue of the
actor
himself poison is the realm of
transitive action
like building a table that's an action
that produces something outside yourself
by aristotle's distinction the realm of
the of the arts and of economic
production is strictly speaking
outside the boundaries of the ethical
but i think that distinction is a
mistake
the assumption that our actions can be
confined to ourselves that we can engage
in praxis
without producing anything outside
ourselves
however aristotelian austin is in other
respects she implicitly rejects this
distinction for
she knows implicitly that every action
is poetic it's productive
the effects of our actions are never
confined simply to ourselves we always
produce and proliferate effects
in the world all actions are transitive
austin's villains don't recognize this
henry and mary crawford in mansfield
park are individualists
in the sense that they follow their own
desires regardless of what the
authorities say or do
when sir thomas bertram is away on
business they take part in a theatrical
production at mansfield park
even though they're warned that the
production that the master of the house
would disapprove
and even over the initial objections of
edmond who's responsible for maintaining
the house
in his father's absence more subtly the
crawfords have no sense
that their actions have consequences
beyond themselves
when henry runs off with maria bertram
now mrs rushworth
mary crawford still hopes that edmund
will marry her
will marry mary she's utterly insensible
to the fact
that her brother's scandal might affect
her
in some way
she sees herself as completely
disconnected from her brother's
immoral action austin's characters
experience moral illumination and growth
as we heard last night from james bowman
and her novels are designed to train
readers as well
and i want to close with a few
observations about how this is so how
her novels
are designed to be moral training for
the reader
first since the moral life is lived
within a particular social setting
excuse me austin is deeply concerned
with moral education
and guidance moral guides are needed in
part because language and manners
can function as disguises the critic
tony tanner
has made the point well in his book on
austin for austin good manners are
essential to preserving
social order and living the moral life
yet in the very places and times when
manners are most on display
they are most difficult to read
correctly
a ball is an occasion for a country
village to parade
and act and practice its codes of
conduct
a ball is an inherently theatrical
occasion
when everyone is acting according to the
script of manners
but then how can you tell when somebody
is acting his acting
being insincere in his acting or
actually being sincere about his manners
everyone finds frank churchill's manners
pleasing but in the book at least emma
can't quite figure out what he truly was
and we know that elizabeth bennett's
first impressions of wickham and darcy
formed during a ball are badly mistaken
like cliches and dead metaphors manners
can
dull the mind smooth style can charm
seduce
and obscure rather than reveal character
austin's heroines need training in
hermeneutics
in interpretation in order to discern
the moral substance of words
and gestures that they encounter
austin's books are among other things
exercises
in moral suspicion by tracing the
surface contours of characters and
situations
she trains her readers to distinguish
true actors from duplicitous ones
second austin's measured style models
the kind of truth-telling that's
required to live with moral integrity
austin's characters must learn above all
to see and tell the truth about
themselves to recognize
as james bowman said when they are wrong
i cannot express my own abhorrence of
myself cries marianne dashwood
when elizabeth bennett recognizes the
truth about wickham she's devastated
how humiliating is this discovery yet
how
just a humiliation
how to understand it all emma woodhouse
asks
in at the moment of her illumination how
to understand the deceptions she had
been practicing on herself
and living under we become truth tellers
at least in part when we mimic the
precision of austin's
style to tell the truth we have to
renounce the mind-dulling metaphors
and cliches that kill thought and
promote groupthink
truth-telling requires the
self-restraint to speak what we know
to fall silent when we're ignorance and
to check the emotions that cloud our
discernment
it demands that we do more than express
our passing sensations
and whims as mrs elton was doing in that
passage i read
truth-telling depends on clarity and
charity of vision on courage and tact
i'm afraid i've made austin sound
ponderous and priggish
nothing of course could be further from
the truth she is among the most
bemused and amusing writers in english
literature
not in spite of her moral firmness but
because of it
as lewis observed the hardcore morality
and even of religion seems to
me to be just what makes good comedy
possible
were there no norm nothing can be
ridiculous
except for a brief moment of unbalanced
provincialism
in which we may laugh at the merely
unfamiliar unless there is something
about which the author is never ironical
there can be no true irony in the work
so austin's moral clarity is what
enables her to write splendid
scenes like the one where eleanor and
marianne dashwood first encountered
robert ferris
at a jewelry shop in sense and
sensibility
robert ignoring all the other customers
is engaged in a grandiose quest
for the perfect toothpick case
this is from sense and sensibility he
was giving orders
for a toothpick case for himself until
its
size shape and ornaments were determined
all of which after examining and
debating for a quarter of an hour
over every toothpick case in the shop
were finally arranged by his own
inventive fancy
he had no leisure to bestow any other
attention on the two ladies
than what was comprised in three or four
very broad
stairs a kind of notice which served to
imprint on eleanor the remembrance of a
person and face
of strong natural sterling
insignificance though adorned in the
first style of fashion
at last the affair was decided the ivory
the gold the pearls
all received their appointment and the
gentleman having named the last day on
which his existence
could be continued without the
possession of this toothpick case
drew on his glove with leisurely care
and bestowing another glance on the miss
dashwoods but such a one as seemed
rather to demand
than express admiration walked off with
a happy air
of real conceit and affected
indifference that is
a masterpiece of comic writing most
particularly in the central description
of the impression that robert leaves
on eleanor when austin follows a string
of adjectives
like strong natural sterling
with the noun insignificance
you can hear robert vera's deflating
he's a man of style without sumpture
substance punctured
by the repeated pricks of austin's moral
comedy
eleanor might well echo elizabeth
bennett's evaluation of collins letter
there is something pompous in robert's
manners
in austin comedy morality and style form
a chord
of three stand strands her stylistic
miniaturism focuses our attention on
everyday life
where her comic insight exposes the
absurd insubstantiality of every
mere facade charlotte bronte
notwithstanding
austin's chinese fidelity her miniature
delicacy
her self-professed devotion to find
brushwork on a sliver of ivory
is not a defect it's the vehicle of her
moral
vision and the foundation of her moral
art
thank you
thank you dr lightheart we do have some
time for q
a if you have a question please make
your way to one of the side aisles
so i think what i'm going to say is is
instructive to young people
what does what does emma represent
well she's on one hand a busybody
she's actively talking with people she
finds out
she drives towards our goal sometimes
illusional but she wants to accomplish
something what is the practical value
the practical value is for young people
nowadays
is to be a busybody but a different
level
read different things find out ask
questions
exchange ideas be a person who's active
who's driving towards a goal through
that process you're going to be
standing out you're going to accomplish
more you're going to be noticed
you're going to be more successful
i'll take that as a comment thank you
oh sure i'm trying to get out of the
spotlight that's why i'm moving around
hi thank you so much for your talk it
was amazing um
i'm wondering in your talk why is truth
revealed in letters in particulars for
example the particular roles that people
play in society and status
if it should ideally supersede these
particulars and reach
higher things more abstract things
sorry um why is truth revealed
in jane austen's novels in letters and
particulars
if it should ideally supersede these
constructs and reach
more abstract things if you know what i
mean yeah i i think i know if i if i
don't answer the question
we you can try it again
well i think that uh austin is austin
definitely believes in
uh and she uses abstract moral
categories
uh and she uses them a lot the kind of
the kind of uh
abstract moral categories that were the
the the normal parlance of moralists of
her time so it's it's not that she
avoids that
but uh she she's never talking about
those in kind of
a merely in a theoretical fashion but
they're always they're always
exemplified in particular situations
with with people
who have particular constraints on their
behavior for various reasons
uh and are are called to do certain
things in certain circumstances
so i'm not sure that the i'm not sure
that austin's thinking is
you rise from the particulars to the
universals uh there may be that may be
one part of the movement but i think
it's
probably uh something more like a double
movement you have to rise
from particulars and you do have to work
with some kind of general moral
categories
but then you also have to go back to the
particulars because just living in these
general moral abstractions is not
living a moral life so i think it's a
double movement
and at the point i was trying to make
was the the focus that she
she places on the uh on on the
particulars and as
the place where those abstract qualities
are worked out
is that is that getting at the question
you're asking yeah yeah and were you
asking about
uh the use of letters uh you mentioned
okay so yes letters like for example the
particulars that they go into and some
of the letters like the mannerisms that
are conveyed through letters
giving people their first impressions is
this supposed to be
truth is this supposed to be how you
find truth about certain people
or does is it supposed to exceed ideally
for austin like
those letters yeah well again i think it
yeah
my point that i think it's it's a kind
of double movement i do think it's
it's interesting how much of us much
like the action of austin's novels turns
on
the reception and delivery of letters uh
and
of course this was a this was a a
novelistic style at the time that she
experimented with in some of her early
work
with epistolary novels james bowman made
passing reference to this last evening
but even when she's not writing an
epistolary novel you know that the
uh elizabeth bennett's uh
recognition of darcy's character partly
comes from visiting his
his home and imagining herself as the
lady of that house
but it also comes from a letter that he
gives and i think there's something
about the
this message from a distance and it
leaves the character
alone with this new information rather
than
always in sometimes it's in the in an
interpersonal conflict a per
interpersonal
exchange like like mr knightley's
uh chiding event of emma that's that
takes place in person
but a lot of the a lot of the new
information comes from outside in the
and the characters left alone
to try to assess this new information
try to adjust
recognize the wrongness of what they had
been thinking in isolation
yeah so this may be less of a like
writing style question more of like a
life application question you mentioned
like 15 minutes into the lecture uh most
of the characters have this like hearty
relish for modest pleasures
uh so i'm a psych major so one of the
things that we talk about all the time
is how like our generation the previous
generation some of their biggest
qualms with life is like a general lack
of meaning or general like lack of
pleasure in things
it seems to finite in many ways so would
you
chalk that down to a like there's no
real appreciation for the most pleasures
anymore or just a general lack of
modesty in society today
yeah that's a that's a really good
question it's hard to generalize about
what's happening i think uh
a couple things i would say um i don't
think this is i'm going beyond austin
here
uh expressing my own uh my own views
about and saying it the way i would have
i think there's there's probably
a uh something like a metaphysical
deficit
in that experience that is
a failure to appreciate
what what reality is and i think that's
a
there's a theological and religious
dimension to that
if you believe that reality is
from top to bottom a gift of an infinite
god
then there's you know the smallest
delight
uh is uh is worthy of your attention and
and pleasure
uh and if you don't if you think that
this is just a a product of chance and
and long periods of time then you have a
different you have a different uh
you have a different metaphysics a
different conception and i also think of
the
a number of theologians of late have
been calling attention to the medieval
notion of
sloth the term is acedia
it's uh it's it would be the term that
dante uses in the
in the in the inferno
acidi is not just laziness but acidia is
a
just a complete lack of delight in the
world
a complete it's it's kind of the
whatever mentality i've i've done that
there's nothing in the world that's
going to interest or delight me
and i think there's a jadedness to uh
maybe particularly younger generations i
don't know if that's the case but
it may have something to do with the the
uh the ways that technologies have taken
over
uh the lack of contact with the with an
unmediated world i think there's
there's something in that but there's
this there's this general mood of acedia
that i think is
uh has a number of different routes but
that that's that's how i would describe
it
i was interested by your point and i
definitely saw the relevance of it how
austin handles morality
as applied to what is expected of
someone as a member of a certain social
class or something
standing so i'm curious on your thoughts
on the end of pride and prejudice even
though things with lydia all patched up
clearly something wasn't right though so
is dosey
essentially going against that norm or
do we think austin's saying there's
something
stronger and different and even more
valuable to what he did
instead of just avoiding her family
because of that
yeah i i agree with what james bowman
said last evening that she took
she took the uh classic class system for
granted i don't think she's a critic of
it
but i think that i think we can we can
misunderstand what
the class system is about and miss and
particularly misunderstand the
the the the obligations
that um upper classes
had in in a traditional in a traditional
english society
they weren't just being being a master
of a great house was not just a
privilege
a privilege of wealth and you know
possibility of command
but it also imposed obligations to care
for those
who were under your under your uh
authority
or or dependent on you in some way
mr knightley i think is a great uh
illustration of that kind of
that kind of nobility as a status but
also as
a character trait and it involves
charity
and it involves things like what darcy
does to
to resolve the scandal of the bennett
family i think that's
that's an act of that's an act of
excessive charity obviously coming out
of
his affection for elizabeth in large
part but it's also an act of charity
that's consistent with the obligations
that would be placed on somebody instead
in his status
so yeah i think that that's
i i don't think that i think it's a we
tend to misunderstand what status is
about in
in austin's time and it it had both
obligations and privileges attached to
it
um so you mentioned um
that people in austin's day had to find
out
um you know like perceive someone's
character through good manners and
dialogue
and then you also talked about how
austin describes a lot of the scenes and
characters through dialogue
do you think that she's trying to get
her readers to practice that same
perception
of characters and of the situation from
the dialogue that her heroines have to
practice
yes i do i think that's i think that it
was
this is a this a kind of ancient
notion of literary of the purposes of
literature which is never simply to
delight but to delight and instruct
so i think that the the design is not
just to
tell a good story you know to to elicit
the oohs and the odds that i heard in
the audience during the
closing scenes of emma that's part of it
she wants to write stories that are
interesting and that
have this kind of emotional charge but
she intends to instruct and she's trying
to get
trying to provide her readers with tools
maybe models in order to discern
uh between the as i as i described it is
that
the true actors and duplicitous ones um
stanley fish kind of a radical critic
wrote his i think his first book he was
a milton scholar early on
and one of his first books i think his
first book was called surprised by sin
it's about paradise lost
and his argument was that the attraction
of satan in in paradise lost is not an
error on milton's part but it's part of
the design of the
poem you have you have romantic
romantic readers like william blake who
think that
satan is the hero of the poem fish says
that that's
not at all milton's intention and milton
didn't lose
control of his character he wants to
make satan attractive because he wants
to put the reader through the same
experience of temptation
that the characters are going through
and i think that kind of that kind of
moral
rhetoric is part of austin's design too
she's trying to put
her readers through the same kind of
process of discernment
illumination of their own their own
feelings
so there's that i think there's
definitely that moral character to it
so you mentioned the 39 articles
and the church of england but reading
austin's novels and watching the movies
especially
i don't see much like religion
explicitly mentioned
is there a reason for that and would you
say that
those particulars and jane austen's life
um those aspects of her life
that they affected her novels in um
subtle ways and how how would they how
did they do that
yeah a couple of things first of all i
think there's
more uh religious interest
overtly in austin's novels than we
sometimes
recognize there are a lot of clergymen
some of the clergymen are are parodied
i'm collins and elton particularly but
not all of them and and even i mean
there's a there's a long a christian
tradition of
poking fun at the clergy i mean that's
that's not a new thing with jane austen
um but you also have characters like
edmund
edmund bertram in uh in mansfield park
which is i think
mansfield park is the most overtly
theological and religious
of her novels and um there are
ex there are conversations with between
mary crawford and
ed edmund bertram about the vocation of
a minister
mary crawford is a kind of temptress
trying to divert
edmond from his vocation which is to
enter the ministry and be a priest
and he sees his role as being one of uh
kind of uh it's not a
high position socially but he sees it as
a
cr as crucial to developing
communities and developing moral human
beings
so he sees this as a very high calling
and mary crawford is trying to belittle
it
so you have some overt discussions like
that and there have been some critics
and i think there's something to this
there have been some critics who've
suggested
uh i i don't remember who it was but
described austin's
romances as being anglican romances
there's a there are uh
the very various considerations that go
into the resolution of a romance in
austin
um obviously there's attraction
uh there's compatibility of uh of taste
and
temper money is an important oh
and that's not cynical she knows that
money is an important consideration
but there's also something happens that
that's just
um inexplicable there's there's this
kind of uh
i don't know you call it magic or grace
you could uh
they shouldn't use that terminology not
often but there's
something else that's active in those
romances that that brings out the happy
ending
so i think there's something to it it is
it is uh background in in many of her
novels it's not it's not foregrounded
but i think it's
i think it's there and just personally i
mean she grew up in a
home of a church of england uh priest
uh she had brothers who were involved
who were who were
uh who were priests in the church of
england she was surrounded by it
she was she she had her entire life was
in the church of england so
it doesn't come out overtly that may be
a matter of
that may also be the anglicanism of her
romances because you know
anglicans tend to be a little bit
reticent about their faith
not not as not as they don't tend to be
as effusive as evangelicals are
in answer to another student's question
you mentioned that
jane austen frequently utilizes the
message from a distance in order to make
her
characters encounter a moral challenge
however in your talk you also mentioned
that the greatest moral challenges occur
in the midst of daily life
so i'm curious what you believe is the
significance
in connection to those two how she makes
the characters
make the decision within a social
setting but also encounter those
challenges
in solitude yeah yeah i wouldn't put
those two in opposition to each other i
think that
the the letter that elizabeth bennett
receives for example
is about the things that have happened
in those different
social settings uh the misjudgments that
she's made
the fir the the wrong impressions that
she's formed about different characters
and there's that moment of her being
isolated but it's
it's integrated into that larger social
setting so i wouldn't put those two in
opposition
they're uh yeah they're different
moments within the everyday life that
they're
experiencing did you have want to follow
up
um so do you believe is it is it
necessary for
each character to have that solitude
after
like in order to process the social
setting or not necessarily
yeah i'd have to i'd have to think more
about specifics to know if that happens
in every case i think there's a
uh there are different degrees of it i
guess
i just have to i'd have to think through
examples thanks
hi um just a particular uh pride and
prejudice question
at the toward the end of the novel um as
elizabeth is kind of waking up to the
fact that uh darcy might be worth her
while
she reflects pretty critically on her
parents
and you know i think her father comes
out better for it but her mother
comes out worse for the wear and in one
sense
what you can see is she's so she's so
acute to the way in which
her mother kind of sends against social
norms
um and so she's understanding uh how her
mother in her own ways are kind of bore
in another it seems like such a such a
betrayal of another kind of local thing
that we should care about which is
uh you know the relationship that one
has with her mother and the like
particular good way in which a mother
has
has reared her daughter i'm just curious
as to what you think of that
yeah that's a good question and i'd have
to think more about how to sort through
that
a couple things occur to me one is that
i think the part of what's going on in
those latter scenes is that elizabeth is
beginning to
see her family through darcy's eyes
and uh she she recognizes
the the flaws in her family in a way
that she hadn't before and
um it it makes sense to her why darcy
would have worn bingley off from
her family so i think that's that's
actually
it's part of her part of the process of
her falling in love with darcy they're
you know becoming one taking on a
united mind um and it's also part of her
recognition of her own circumstances i
don't think that i don't think there's
anything
i'd have to look at the particular
passages i don't think there's anything
disrespectful i think it's truthful and
i'm not sure
i'd agree that her her mother comes off
worse
i think her uh her dad is a lot funnier
and well her mother's pretty funny but
her dad's a lot more calm and laid back
and
but i mean the the mess in the family is
largely his negligence you could say i
had a student
years ago who did a senior thesis
on the absent fathers in austin's novels
which is a is a recurring theme uh and
i think yeah mr bennett is uh
willing to retire into his library with
a book when he should be
doing something else he's willing for
somebody else to clean up the messes
that his family makes
and you had the passage that james
bowman talked about last night where
mr bennett has this moment of a sort of
uh penitence but he's he
he realizes that it will pass and that
he'll go back and read a book
in his library again so i think they
i don't think that's i don't think it's
i don't see it as a disrespect i'd have
to i'd have to look at it more carefully
but uh
i wouldn't see it as disrespect but it
is an an insight into the
fells faults of her family which i don't
think is a uh
i don't think that's a that's a matter
of disrespect or dishonor to her
to her parents for one more question
all right last question promise um so as
far as comedy today
yeah yeah yeah i'm mark
nice to meet you um so yeah you as well
yeah well hey best for last i guess um
anyway so as far as comedy today
um a lot of it's based on instant
gratification if you look like movie
numbers for the last seven years or so
there hasn't really been a successful
comedy movie especially one that's well
rated
um as well as what we're talking about
with jane austen how she has a lot of
like subtle implied
uh practical comedy and a lot of her
writing um
do you think that that could be perhaps
why at least people today have a
difficult time or
younger people today have a difficult
time finding that humor because for me
personally my mom had to give me a heads
up beforehand that jane austen was funny
before i took
the lecture series and that's the
someone who's watched pride and
prejudice three times with her before
so yeah well i'm glad your mother gave
you the heads up mark that's
that's good yeah if you don't realize
that then you're in you're in trouble
um yeah well um i don't know if whit
stillman is in the room but uh
i would i think that if you're looking
for austin-esque humor
in films uh his films are among the best
recent films i mean the the one
straight austin adaptation he did love
and friendship which is an adaptation of
lady susan
um is hilarious uh not just because the
lady susan character is so deliciously
evil
but they're just there are some some
really uh really uh amusing
bombastic other characters in the film i
think it's
austin's style of humor the passage i
read at the end from sense and
sensibility a lot of that depends
on the way that austin describes what's
happening
so it's it's not the situation is
already
uh ridiculous because you have this very
wealthy man
uh who's spending an enormous amount of
time and energy to
to get the exact uh exact
design of this very trivial object that
he's interested in
inconveniencing everyone else around him
in order to get this
so you have that that kind of uh comic
folly that's there but it's really a lot
of it isn't the way that
she describes it and describes robert so
that's very hard to translate into film
i think
uh and um so i i yeah i'd
uh i i maybe i'd maybe i'll go back to
uh
another thing that i mentioned in the in
the paper
um i think maybe lewis's discussion of
the religious and moral ground for
comedy
would be as good an explanation as
anything
and his point was that if you
you need something about which you are
never
ironical in order to have irony work
and we live in a world where irony just
goes all the way down to the ground
there is nothing that is doesn't doesn't
dissolve by irony
uh austin is not like that and so the
best the best humorists are going to be
the ones that have some kind of
some kind of firm convictions about the
world so they can as louis says that
they can recognize the ridiculous when
it happens
and i think that maybe that's what's
that moral or religious groundwork is
what's lacking in a lot of
contemporary comedy um because you you
need that you need to have some standard
of comparison in order to show that
something is
is absurd thanks
you